hey we put your hands on the steering
wheel properly
see
a kid or a dog ran out right now and you
got hands down here what how you gonna
do this
what are you gonna do
i'm comedian ryan sickler and this is my
stepson derek crawford while we were on
quarantine class might have been out but
school was still in session all right
let's go
very serious business you have lives
especially this one
and your literal hands and feet
it was like an old country road and it
had an awesome hill to jump jumping them
yeah dude we jumped the [ __ ] out of them
oh no hold on
look at it
look at aloha
just heavy on the brakes i mean jesus
christ stay in your lane you're hurting
jerky with turns this is learner's
permit
all right let's go check out beverly
hills today let's go look at
some of these houses
[Music]
i try to count one day i went and did a
little tour when i was home one time of
all the places i lived
so our first house was west baltimore
and then we lived there for a while and
then moved out to this place called
winfield in carroll county for like felt
like 10 seconds
[Music]
that's a cop right there and dude well
first of all you herky jerked into this
lane and then you double-thought it you
cut back blinker the whole time left and
you went again then you committed you
lucky it's corona i know you saw that i
know they saw that
[Laughter]
you got to be careful if you commit just
go all you have to do is turn around
somewhere else it is not worth cutting
over at the last second on the freeway
and rolling the car and killing your
family
just because you got to get that exit
winfield that's my younger brother was
born and then we moved to houston
for maybe about a year spring texas i
learned how to climb trees in texas i
learned how to swim in texas texas was
very important in my my development and
then we went back to maryland because
everybody was missing maryland nobody
from our family was there but us this
guy shirtless but a mask on
i mean
i'm about to give him something oh the
bus ruined the son of a [ __ ] no one's
on it oh yeah there are oh
look out hit the gas that's a coven
missile right there
[Music]
so we moved back we moved into this
house it's my favorite house
yeah iron gate circle it was a big house
i shared a room with my brother and then
my younger brother had his own room and
then our grandmother our mom's mom lived
there she lived there and she would
smoke cigarettes in the house and
all she would eat was peanuts and like
diet pepsi
that was it
grandma devito drove this mint green
buick let's get across the street sean
flynn are we still talk on facebook and
stuff he beat the [ __ ] out of me one
time i mean he beat the [ __ ] out of me
i'm just kid but he he could fight i
remember going inside my dad's like what
are you crying about and i was like sean
you know doing that oh just
he said well what happened i said why i
called him an idiot and he said what'd
he do he said say it again and he's like
and you said it again i said yeah and he
said well you are an idiot and then he
went out and he's like sean
don't be beating my kid up on my
property take him over to your house and
do that [ __ ] so as sean kept beating me
up you know and people call bullying
whatever i think it's good for you not
bullying i don't mean bullying i mean
you know someone that that challenges
you and and and makes you really check
yourself and grow quick i don't think
it's a bad thing but
i eventually got a little stronger and
then
one day i jimmy super fly snuck him
snooking him off the top of that mint
green buick and then i put him in a
headlock and i just [ __ ] him up and he
went home crying i was like [ __ ] yeah
and then it was just like
back and forth
all the time but we ended up being
really good friends and i i appreciated
it yeah it was it was it was good that
stuff will build you
[Music]
so iron gate circle that's the best
house that was the best house ever your
favorite of all well our family was
together you know at that time before
the divorce and everything too and it
was like my dad's mom would come up that
was carmella and we'd push our twin beds
together and she would sleep in the
middle and tell stories all night long
and we would laugh and my little brother
was over there we used to torture him
because we lay in bed we'd lay there and
we go god we just whisper and he would
go why and we wasn't saying anything and
we'd be going todd like what
and we would just go todd he'd go what
and he'd be like trying he could want
like todd and go what
and then our mother like you guys better
be quiet out there and then she he'd be
like they're yelling my name they're
whispering my name and we would be dying
laughing and we'd let it settle down
and then we were like god and he's like
what
what and she's like god damn it i'm
coming out there and she would come up
he's like they're saying my name you get
mad at some kids he's so complete is
he's they're saying our name but he's so
young he doesn't get the fact that he
can ignore us he thinks he has to answer
you know i mean and we are pissing
ourselves and she comes in and turns the
light on we just go dead like
like that and just it's like i know
you're not sleeping and we'd be just
holding it hold it and then she go down
the stairs we'd hear and we wait ten
minutes because we know like she's gonna
stand outside the door we long gamed it
and then we'd be like
god he's like what like i hear you all
up there oh god it would make my stomach
hurt i would piss my pants laughing at
that
[Music]
[Music]
you